[Música]
y
i
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bienvenidos a francia en focus programa
sobre la actualidad francesa en esta
edición comenzaremos hablando de los
semiconductores la unión europea quiere
producirlos y para eso va a invertir
hasta unos 43.000 millones de euros y
así no depender de los fabricantes
asiáticos luego hablaremos de arte en
concreto de las 15 obras de arte que
francia va a restituir a las familias
judías que fueron expoliadas durante la
alemania nazi y por último les traeremos
los perfiles de dos candidatos a la
elección o presidencial aquí en francia
en el próximo mes de abril a se trata de
marín lópez y de eriksen
[Música]
los semiconductores forman parte de
nuestra vida diaria están en los
automóviles en los teléfonos celulares
en los computadores sin embargo
comenzaron a escasear con la
reactivación de la economía tras la
pandemia y también con todos los
problemas que ha habido en la cadena de
suministros sin embargo europa quiere
ahora producirlos y espera de aquí a
diez años hacerse con el 20 por ciento
de esa cuota de mercado en niza francia
hay una de esas sofisticadas fábricas de
semiconductores
[Música]
al verlos caminar con sus trajes azules
de la cabeza a los pies uno tiene la
impresión de haber entrado a un reactor
nuclear un laboratorio químico
aquí el entorno que nos rodea es mil
veces más limpio que un quirófano así
que la más mínima partícula de polvo de
piel puede hacer que los microchips
queden inservibles
[Música]
los microchips son el nuevo tesoro de la
economía son indispensables para
nuestros teléfonos autos y equipos
informáticos los semiconductores están
en todas partes aunque la mayoría
procede de taiwán esta fábrica y ser al
sudoeste de francia se ha abierto un
espacio de este mercado ultramoderna
miles de robots del suelo al techo cada
pequeño rectángulo es un microchip se
recortan al final del proceso de
fabricación y hay cerca de 1.000 de
ellos en esta placa de silicio es el
componente básico de todos los
dispositivos electrónicos que todo el
mundo utiliza en la tierra de miles de
millones de dispositivos electrónicos
son imprescindibles pero su fabricación
requiere muchísimo tiempo pues está
formado por varias capas un microchip
debe pasar tres meses en estas máquinas
un microchip es como un edificio de 30
pisos para que un microchip funcione
tienen que haberse construido 30 pisos
de espesor con un ángulo preciso
para hacer frente al gran aumento de la
demanda el grupo aumenta su producción
en un 25% cada año
unos tienen de aquí al final de año sólo
en 2022 se invertirán aquí casi 1000
millones de euros y no solo en robots en
la parte inferior de este edificio
tenemos un proyecto para crear un centro
de formación que nos permita integrar
todas las competencias técnicas que
necesitamos en el sitio intentamos
levantar los muros y ocupar el
territorio lo mejor posible si se quiere
convertirse en el silicon valley del
microchip tiene que reclutar en masa
incluidos los subcontratistas a dos
kilómetros de distancia a este proveedor
de componentes ha doblado su personal en
cinco años hasta alcanzar 1600 empleados
geraldine con su madre de familia ha
estado desempleada sus opciónes llevaba
seis meses buscando es un alivio estaba
feliz tenemos una seguridad pero muchos
también son contratados directamente al
terminar sus estudios la oficina de
ingenieros parece incluso un salón de
clases la empresa que se encarga de
reclutar para este tipo de google aún
necesita contratar a 300 personas y
puede que esto sea sólo el principio la
fábrica podría beneficiarse el fondo
europeo para crecer
actualmente europa tiene muy poca
capacidad de producción a nivel mundial
apenas un 10% la ambición es llegar al
20 por ciento el 20 por ciento será
enorme no se espera que el mercado de
los microchips electrónicos alcance los
mil millones de dólares en todo el mundo
en cinco años un gran pastel del cual
desear espera llevarse un gran trozo
durante la segunda guerra mundial los
nazis expoliaron cerca de 100 mil obras
a las familias judías francia ha estado
investigando si entre sus colecciones
nacionales hay algunas de estas obras
para poderlas devolver a sus dueños de
hecho el pasado mes de febrero la
asamblea nacional aprobó un proyecto de
ley para devolver 15 de estas obras
entre ellas un lienzo del pintor francés
maurice utrillo
desde hace casi cuatro años ha estado en
un lugar seguro conservado en esta
bodega cuya ubicación es secreta donde
están guardadas miles de obras de arte
en unos meses el cuadro de maurice
utrillo será devuelto a su propietario
legal 92 años después de haber sido
robado por los nazis de la casa del
coleccionista judío george wehrheim este
es el kart furas anual
es muy emocionante devolverle este
cuadro al legatario universal el alcalde
de sant ya lo había comprado de buena fe
para su museo sin saber que se trataba
de una obra expoliada no tengo para nada
la impresión de que me estén quitando
esta obra esta obra no me pertenece de
hecho el arte no le pertenece a nadie se
va a encontrar con su familia con el
lega tario universal de la familia ben
haim si se trata simplemente de hacer
justicia fue necesaria una investigación
hace siete años para descubrir el pasado
del cuadro la historiadora de arte
elizabeth roger greenblatt especialista
en obras expoliadas estaba trabajando en
los cuadros de utrillo cuando se dio
cuenta de que la obra figuraba en los
archivos alemanes
[Música]
al mirar con la lupa es posible ver que
hay una pequeña mancha en la firma nos
dimos cuenta de que la foto de este
cuadro estaba entre los documentos de la
lr el servicio a cargo del pillaje de
grandes colecciones youtube
pierde con conexión no cabía duda
efectivamente se trataba de un cuadro
robo jaime y la mayoría de los cuadros
habían sido llevados a la galería donde
pop para que el joven pudiera escoger
considerado demasiado moderno por góring
en 1942 el cuadro se intercambió por la
biblioteca de un coleccionista volvería
a aparecer varios años después en el
mercado del arte de berlín luego en una
colección en medio oriente en una
galería en parís y finalmente en londres
en 2004 en las subastas de xosé bis
donde fue comprado por la ciudad de
sanya
la ciudad de sanya compró el cuadro en
showbiz por 150 mil euros de los cuales
74 mil fueron a sus expensas era la
pieza principal del museo y sólo 18 años
después la ciudad se enteró de la
historia del cuadro por un simple correo
del ministerio de cultura para sacar una
obra de arte del dominio público es
necesaria una ley y el alcalde había
estado esperando su aprobación desde
hacía años
faltaba identificar al heredero del
cuadro un giro inesperado el
genealogista mateo antiguo descubrió en
un testamento que el derechohabiente no
era el miembro de la familia ben haim
y terry
el legatario universal que encontramos
es un amigo de la vida del hijo del
señor george bear jaime este cuadro tal
vez regrese a una casa de subastas será
vendido pero esta vez será vendido por
el verdadero propietario
el amigo de la familia que desea
mantenerse anónimo aún no ha dicho si
quiere conservar el cuadro un óleo sobre
lienzo valorado en 120.000 euros cuya
historia tal vez está lejos de haber
terminado
continuamos con la serie de perfiles de
los candidatos a la presidencia francesa
en esta ocasión les contaremos a quienes
ha marginal open la heredera de la
ultraderecha en su tercer intento por
llegar al inicio
desde pequeña la política ha sido su
mundo
es asunto de familia en casa de los
léperos
su padre es romay y le pen líder del
frente nacional partido de extrema
derecha
[Música]
cada vez que atacaban a su padre martin
salía a defenderlo así nació su vocación
por el derecho en política comenzó muy
joven
llegó a su primer cargo público en 1998
como consejera regional del norte de
cali su padre ya empezaba a verla como
su sucesor
comenzó entonces su misión suavizar la
imagen de su padre y desmarcarse de él
soy marín y penn
siempre he sido marín dependiendo marín
diop en que no soy el clon de mi padre
el 21 de abril de 2002 momento histórico
para arrumbar paso a la segunda vuelta
de la elección presidencial frente a
jacques chirac la hija fue subiendo
escalones y en 2011 llegó su hora ahora
es ella la comandante del barco familiar
la consigna desestigmatizar su frente
nacional
a los hombres a las mujeres cristianos
judíos musulmanes heterosexuales
homosexuales no creyentes somos por
encima de todos franceses
la estrategia funcionó su electorado se
amplió y en 2014 ganó las elecciones
europeas así como una docena de
alcaldías y más de 1500 escaños en los
consejos regionales
llegada a la hora de matar al padre
políticamente lo expulsó del partido que
él mismo fundó una fractura irreparable
pues nunca más se les volverá a ver
juntos sobre una tarima
[Aplausos]
en su segundo intento por llegar a la
presidencia en 2017 marín igualó a su
padre pero perdió en la segunda vuelta
frente a emanuel marcó el vamos
para conseguir la victoria hay que
remodelar la casa empezando por la
fachada adiós al frente nacional nace
reagrupación nacional marine le pen
quería salir del euro y de la unión
europea pero esas ideas quedaron atrás
la línea de su partido es menos radical
algo que no agrada al papá romaric que
tiene una nueva protegida su nieta mayo
más real
la política es y seguirá siendo un
asunto de familia
[Música]
una de las sorpresas de esta campaña
presidencial ha sido la entrada en liza
de herri que es de mucho un polémico
comentarista de televisión que ha venido
a irrumpir con el monopolio que tenía lo
pena de la extrema derecha eric the move
tiene 63 años nació en monto débil norte
de parís sus padres judíos sefardíes
llegaron a francia tras huir de la
guerra en argelia en los años 50 su
carrera como periodista comenzó en la
prensa escrita pero fue su paso por la
televisión lo que lo catapultó como
figura pública con sus polémicas en
programas de debate
la mayoría de los traficantes son negros
es así es un hecho
se ha destacado como enemigo de lo
políticamente correcto con un discurso
racista y en contra del islam not for
its y nicaragua nuestra política de
inmigración se basa en tres pilares
primero detener el flujo de inmediato
desde la primera semana de mi mandato de
inmigración cero será una meta clara de
nuestra política
en su primera campaña presidencial una
de sus banderas es frenar la inmigración
para luchar contra el gran reemplazo un
concepto de la extrema derecha según el
cual los franceses serían reemplazados
por la inmigración desbordante el gran
reemplazo no es un mito es un proceso
ineludible que si no lo detenemos nos va
a llevar a todos
demus quiere devolverle a francia su
grandeza de otrora y apuesta a liderar
la extrema derecha reconquistando el
electorado más radical que imaginé open
ha descartado
hasta aquí esta edición de francia en
foco gracias por acompañarnos continúen
con nuestra programación en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom